[Musique]
le docteur arruda qui en point de presse
aujourd'hui à remercier les québécois
pour leur discipline dit ça a marché on
à aplatir la courbe
on le voit le nombre de nouveaux cas
chut jour après jour karl weiss 487 avec
nous dr weiss bonsoir alors on voit où
on peut dessiner là si on relit les
petits points on voit la tendance qui
redescend d'un plateau et qui
éventuellement va redescendre vers le
bas êtes vous du même avis c'est à dire
vous regardez aussi les augmentations et
vous vous êtes on n'est vraiment pas
loin du fameux péclat moi je serais
extrêmement prudents parce qu'en premier
lieu on ne teste pas tout le monde donc
il ya beaucoup de cas à cause des
limites de tests communs il ya beaucoup
de cas qui ne sont pas testés mais tant
on sait très bien qu'ils sont malades
parce qu'on est limité par le nombre de
tests
la deuxième chose le nombre
d'hospitalisations continue d'augmenter
et la troisième chose on a
malheureusement énormément de décès dans
les centres de soins prolongés
donc oui on a fait beaucoup d'efforts il
ya eu certainement un impact majeur du
confinement sur le nombre de cas qu'on
aurait eu parce que si on n'avait rien
fait ça aurait été un scénario
catastrophique dantesque quasiment mais
on est encore trop je dirais trop tôt
pour tirer des conclusions qu'ils soient
trop intimes
d'autant plus qu'on voit encore que dans
les chu celle dé la situation est loin
d'être réglée les décès sont sont loin
d'être réglés non car il ya eu
certainement un impact de tout ça parce
qu'il peut pas ne pas en avoir mais je
serai prudent d'en mesurer mon analyse
pour l'instant surtout sachant qu'on ne
teste pas tout le monde
alors on a moins de cas mais parce qu'on
ne teste pas tout le monde non plus
quand mon peut-être le tester
initialement au début avec la même
intensité on teste des gens disent qu'on
considère essentiel pour pouvoir faire
quelque chose donc c'est sûr qu'on va
tester les jean-marie chsct
les travailleurs de la santé les
patients hospitalisés mais si vous êtes
quelqu'un en relativement bonne forme
relativement jeune qui a pas trop de
symptômes on vous testera probants
le n'ont pas ou en tout cas il ya peu de
chances pour voûte est bon alors c'est
donc prudents se dit vous avec les
données et la courbe et on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge quoi c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais il faut surtout pas
relâcher
je veux dire nos moyens il faut pas
crier victoire trop tôt non plus surtout
sachant ce qui se passe dans les airs
d'une tristesse on a parlé hier d'une
tristesse infinie et là on voit qu'il
manque tellement de monde de bras il y
aura des ressources parce qu'on a
annoncé des ressources des hôpitaux vers
les seychelles des ça semblait tracé là
comme transfert c'est l'époque c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué c'est une
logistique qui est très compliqué mais
d'un autre côté on est aussi marc
zanetti guerre il faut savoir mobiliser
des gens mais c'est toujours comme ça
quand quand on se retrouve dans ce genre
de situation catastrophique un petit peu
ou transférer des individus d'un endroit
vers à nantes c'est pas évident et il ya
aussi vous savez il ya tout un
apprentissage à faire en termes de
donner des soins elle et les infirmières
qui donnent des soins et elles vont vous
dire aux soins intensifs n'ont pas la
même approche avec les patients que les
infirmières des chsct c'est tout à fait
normal parce que ces deux mondes
différents avec deux types de soins
différents donc on peut pas transposer
du jour au lendemain les soins intensifs
au chu
ouais mais ils le font parce qu'il
manque du monde c'est celle là il faut
il faut des médecins il faut des
infirmières il faut aussi beaucoup de
personnel qui est très important de
salubrité préposés aux bénéficiaires etc
c'est pas juste le personnel pure entre
guillemets techniques médicales qui est
important c'est aussi tout le personnel
de soutien qui jouent un rôle
considérable très bientôt acteur 20s
quelques questions du public si vous le
permettez il ya t'il une recherche afin
d'identifier un marqueur commun chez les
patients symptomatiques ont-ils déjà une
maladie similaire autrement dit pourquoi
il ya des gens qui développent à peu
près pas de symptômes alors c'est tout
ce qu'on avait déjà discuté dans le
passé sur l'aspect de la génétique il va
falloir trouver des marqueurs génétiques
et savoir pourquoi certaines personnes
ne vont pas développé de symptômes ne
vont pas développer une maladie alors
que d'autres n'ont développé des
maladies très sévère et on le voit il ya
des gens qui ont été exposés de façon
intense au virus dans par des gens qui
étaient très malades de façon
et péter et ces gens là sont pas malades
développent à peu près aucun symptôme et
il ya d'autres personnes où on voit
qu'ils peuvent faire des maladies très
sévère avec une exposition qui est
l'armé qui porte n'est pas intense
peut-être même un peu douteuse on l'a vu
donc il ya certainement des matchs des
marqueurs génétiques qui font qu'il ya
des gens chez qui la maladie beaucoup
plus sévère pour ce qui est des décès on
le montre les chefs sont claires c'est
vraiment les gens de 70 ans et plus qui
décèdent dans la grande grande majorité
des cas on parle de 90 et plus des cas
mais pour ce qui est des gens
hospitalisés selon ce que vous voyez
vous dr weill est ce qu'il ya des gens
quand même qu'ils étaient en bonne santé
et relativement jeune qui se retrouve à
l'hôpital
je vous dirais que quand vous descendez
en bas de 60 ans les gens qui décèdent
il y en a très très peu c'est des gens
qui ont toujours des problèmes médicaux
sous jacents
donc les gens de 60 ans certains vont
devoir être intubés ça va être difficile
mais à un moment donné si c'est des gens
relativement fort ils vont passer au
travers en outre 60 ans on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya définitivement la changement
dans la dynamique de la maladie et veut
souvent à 11,70 encore plus mais on
s'aperçoit que définitivement péage de
60 ans
il ya un changement dans la dynamique
tous les jambes à 60 ans que j'ai vu
qu'ils ont des problèmes sérieux c'est
des gens qui avaient déjà des facteurs
sous jacents voilà un quart temps
quelqu'un qui est par ailleurs un très
bonne forme qui a
je sais pas moi 50 55 60 ans vous
envoyez à peu près pas hospitalisés oui
on en voit mais on en voit
mais ces gens qui ont tendance à faire
mieux que la plupart des eaux et s'ils
sont en bas 60 ans ils sont hospitalisés
c'est parce que souvent ils ont d'autres
problèmes de santé s'ajoutent est ce que
par contre il faut dire aussi c'est
qu'il ya quand même des cas rapportés
parce qu'il faut pas négliger ça il faut
pas que les gens partent avec le message
que pour moi j'ai 35 ans 40 ans j'ai
aucun problème j'ai pas de danger et on
voit aussi des gens jeunes qui font des
maladies très sévère ils vont s'en
sortir mais ils font des maladies
anormalement sévère pour leur genre de
légende des gens de leur âge bon
n'aurait-il pas été préférable d'imposer
dès le début le confinement seulement
aux personnes de 65 ans et en assurant
parler là mais les choses reviennent que
voulez-vous et et plus et de laisser le
reste la population vaquait à sa place à
ses occupations
le problème c'est que si vous mettez 65
ans et vous mettez la barre à ce niveau
là il ya beaucoup de sous groupes qui
vont réagir différemment et un peu ce
que je vous ai dit un peu plus tôt alors
c'est sûr que en vain 60 entre les 60 et
65 ans ces gens là ont un risque
nettement plus grand que les 50 à 59 les
50 à 59 ans la liste pas tellement plus
grand mais quand même un peu plus grands
qui 40 à 49 et narbonne 40 ont très peu
de rice alors à ce moment là où il
aurait fallu dire ballon va mettre juste
sur 20 40 on va les renvoyer en
circulation mais ces gens là ils sont
cons ils ont des contacts avec les gens
plus âgés
alors qu'est ce qui arriverait si l'on
des contacts avec des gens plus âgés
vous savez on l'a vu dans les sièges
c'est des siens chez celles des eaux
beaucoup c'est souvent des pas toujours
mais c'est peut-être des gens qui ont
introduit le virus sans même le savoir
à l'intérieur du chsct des gens
probablement relativement jeunes qui
sont allés visiter des gens qui ont
travaillé là bas qui ont introduit le
virus et qui par la suite s'est répandue
comme une traînée de poudre et a donné
les conséquences qu'on connaît bon
dernière il ne resterait plus d'un camé
neuf ans pourquoi un si long avant de
trouver le vaccin et vous demande tél
ben c'est parce qu'il faut pas être
pressé c'est juste une question c'est
vrai il ya des malades
ça a pris des siècles la rentrée des
vaccins d'autres des dizaines d'années
alors c'est normal qu'on peut pas avoir
accès efficace et sécuritaire en bas
d'un an
il faut que d'abord le créer le
fabriquer le tester s'assurer qu'ils
fonctionnent et s'assurer qu'ils donnent
pas des problèmes majeurs donc pour la
version les plus courts merci merci
c'est votre sens de l'histoire que
j'aime d'acteurs vaille souci merci à
très bientôt au revoir